So we've been tracking the rise of corona
virus cases in the United States and we started
seeing the numbers spike on June 19th.
There was the idea in late April, early May,
that that was the peak when we had 30000 new
cases a day in April, May.
We were hoping, I guess.
I mean, I certainly was hoping that we were
past the peak, at least the wave one peak.
And it looked like maybe we were until July,
June 19th, when we started seeing cases climb
and climb and climb up to as many as 60 thousand
new cases a day a few days ago, centered around
California and a bunch of red states, including
Arizona, Florida and Texas at the top of that
list.
And what we observed for the last 20 or so
days was that even though the cases were spiking,
the deaths were staying pretty low.
And you can see if you're looking at the chart
of deaths, they've been trending down.
And all along, there were questions about
how is this possible, what's going on.
Now, the most obvious explanation, maybe we
would call it the simplest explanation.
We could say the explanation that requires
the fewest assumptions is that there is simply
a lag between cases and deaths.
You don't die the day you're diagnosed.
So when you see cases spike, you would expect
that it would take some time before those
increased case numbers turn into deaths.
There were other explanations that we considered
as well.
Is it possible that the virus has mutated
to be less deadly?
It's possible we didn't have any evidence
for it.
Is it possible that doctors are getting better
at treating corona virus patients, which is
decreasing the death rate?
Certainly possible.
Could it be that more testing means healthier
people are getting tested?
So even though you have more cases, the share
of cases that are serious could be declining.
And that's why the deaths continue to trend
down.
Or is it younger people getting corona virus
who are less likely to get really sick?
All of these are reasonable possibilities
to wonder about.
But if the explanation is the first one, which
is there is a lag between cases and deaths,
we would expect that somewhere in the range
of 18 to 21 days after the cases spike, deaths
would start to spike 18 to 21 days from the
start of the case.
Spike is this week.
It's yesterday.
It's today.
It's tomorrow.
And sadly, tragically, yesterday, Arizona
and Texas both hit single day death records
dating all the way back to the start of the
pandemic.
Yesterday, we had again nearly 60000 new cases
of corona virus reported and deaths in Arizona
and Texas.
And by the way, also in California, California
is not exempt from this, but it's been mostly
the red state are saying that it's Arizona
and Texas that weren't going to see the death
spike.
They are spiking Arizona with 117 deaths.
Yesterday, Texas with 84 deaths yesterday.
Those are sad.
These are not records we want to be setting.
These are tragic new high marks for a corona
virus.
Deaths in a single day.
Now, I don't want to be alarmist and I hope
that I'm wrong and I believe that I've been
relatively sober in my analysis of Corona
virus from the start.
The simplest explanation is that the deaths
are spiking because the cases spiked 20 days
ago.
And if that's the case in another 10 days,
the death numbers are going to look really,
really bad.
And what I mean by that is cases started to
spike on June 19.
So the small spike in deaths we're seeing
now would be related to the start of the spike
in cases on June 19th, around July 1st.
The new case numbers were dramatically higher
than on June 19th.
And if that tracks as a leading indicator
to eventual deaths in another 10 or 15 days,
we are going to have unconscionable numbers
coming out of some of these states.
It's horrible when we're right about terrible
things.
And this is really, really terrible.
Now, if we want to find something to look
at that looks OK.
There are still some states doing quite well
right now.
The states with the lowest reproduction rate
of the virus are Connecticut, Washington,
D.C., which is not a state.
Maine, New Hampshire, Massachusetts, Rhode
Island, Maryland and Utah, although the reproduction
rate there, what's called the.
Are not.
The R zero.
It's it's starting to creep up.
And what I believe is going on is nothing
that requires any kind of particular insight.
The states that are doing well can only hold
off cases for so long if other states are
a disaster, because travel between states
is constitutionally it's a constitutional
right in the United States, ingress and egress
from in two states.
And when you look at the county level map
of the United States and you see, you know,
the red and orange counties, the ones that
are in trouble, they're right next to counties
that are doing far better.
And so I believe that, sadly, unless there
are some interstate travel restrictions put
in place, which I'm neither recommending nor
do I believe would necessarily be legal, I'm
merely making them sort of mathematical statement.
You're going to see some of the states that
are doing well start to do less.
Well, if cases continue to skyrocket in places
like Florida, Arizona, California, Texas and
many others, I can't even give you the full
list.
Now, I do think also that there are some governors,
including our governor here.
I believe Charlie Baker here in Massachusetts
has widely done a very good job.
And what I'm worried about is they're now
doing the indoor dining in Massachusetts.
I got a message from my gym that it's opening
next Monday.
I think that this is a mistake.
We've done so much work here for the last
four months to get down to only having a couple
hundred new cases a day without a spike.
It's like every day about 200 cases, 200 cases.
It seems to me, given that it's summer, given
that people can do outdoor dining.
Given that people can do outdoor workouts,
I understand the business side of it.
It seems too risky to me to do indoor dining
or to open gyms, movie theaters and some of
the other things being discussed.
I won't be partaking.
I've been doing the outdoor dining.
It feels safe.
It's more than enough.
It's warm out.
I think that that's a risk for the states
that are doing well to do right now.
And I hope that I'm wrong, but the numbers
are truly, truly scary.